do you have each other's codes to the
phone
please know my code
that was you bro
that was you okay so the rule is you
have her code she can't have your code
like if she wanted to code to your phone
would you give it to her you're like nah
you got it
what's wrong what do you mean
you keep laughing because he do he knows
what he's trying to do right now what am
I doing I'm just asking honest questions
no
that's what it is I just don't agree
with it then why are you in my phone
again
like I told you earlier there's only I
only get one I only get one [__] to
care about that I sleep with every night
hey you care if you feel me feel be
careful you got one right yeah my wife
yeah I'm married yes you're not married
and you sure